hundreds of thousands of syrians have
died
millions have been displaced countless
others remain illegally detained
or often tortured missing disappeared
for 10 years the world has watched
serious spiral into destruction
and bloodshed wafer mustafa
is a long way from syria now but she's
still haunted by the nightmares of her
broken nation
water's father ali was a critic of the
syrian regime
he'd been arrested a couple of times in
his hometown and moved to damascus
to lower his profile but in 2013
ali was seized by armed men and nobody
has heard from him since then
family fled syria his daughter wafer now
in berlin
we haven't heard from my dad since then
we haven't been told why he was taken
for what reason what what is he charged
with where
is he i mean for years now
we've been trying just to get an answer
for
one single question is he alive
or not she protests against the assad
regime driven by the
endless stories of suffering in her home
country
i think that the main source of my hope
is my memory
my memory of my dad every time i feel
that um
that this is just pointless
i see someone inside syria protesting in
idlib for example
and after 10 years under the russian
uh bombing uh demanding freedom and
saying that
we do not give up our freedom i mean i
just feel like
do i even have the right to give up hope
we meet her again
outside the russian embassy where wafer
regularly protests against the country's
support for assad's regime
each of these photos is of someone who
was detained
or disappeared or simply killed here
a family group all of them have gone
these pictures are a testament to lives
ripped away
in syria and she still disappeared till
today i mean
her faith is still unknown unfortunately
the war in syria unleashed horrors on
all sides from the barbarity of isis to
the
gruesome cruelty of other groups
but the syrian government stands accused
of callous crimes
of chemical attacks that targeted
schools and hospitals
of torture and murder on an unthinkable
scale
amina is another whose life was ripped
apart
she was detained and held in appalling
conditions her three brothers were
tortured and killed
by those loyal to president assad
um
but the fury isn't just about the horror
pain and destruction
it's also about the sense that the world
has shrugged
and ignored a decade of disaster in
syria
dictatorship
at the united nations russia and china
vetoed a resolution to hold assad
accountable in the criminal court
they've defended him and his government
constantly
but there are signs that the world is
taking syria seriously
in germany a former syrian agent has
been jailed for his involvement in
torture another man remains on trial
and there may be a pathway to holding
president assad personally accountable
and it starts here in the netherlands
the dutch government accuses syria of
breaking the international convention
against torture and says all such abuses
must come to an end if it doesn't get
that guarantee and
few think it will then the path ends
with
charges being levied against president
assad and his ministers here at the
international court of justice now the
problem is
this process would take a long time
years the flip side is
it wouldn't be subject to veto by
diplomats from russia
or china the netherlands have now been
joined by canada in this legal action
the dutch foreign minister told me he's
determined to see justice done
even if it takes time and patience we
have
statements by survivors
we we have those terrible pictures i
think a lot of people
have seen we have the eyewitness
so there is ample evidence
to be used in a court of law but first i
want now
to have serious conversations with the
syrian government i'm afraid
that the wheels of justice often grind
slowly so it might take a couple of
years
but we we will persevere so is it really
worth it
according to one of the lawyers involved
there is a moral duty to act
he says the carnage of syria is a result
of turning a blind eye to atrocities in
previous decades
we are unfortunately paying the cost for
for not having
intervened over the last 40 years in
syria
by what we've seen with more than half a
million people being killed since 2011.
so i think if we let me put it this way
we cannot afford to take the risk
of not taking action now
back in berlin waffle works on she is
exhausted and traumatized but keeps
going
for the sake of her father she hasn't
seen for nearly a decade
who may not even be alive i'm not sure
till when i can do this but i'm sure
that this
is what i want to do and i am sure that
at least today i'm still doing this i
hope that tomorrow i will still be able
to do it
but i'm also sure that if one day
i collapsed and i wasn't able to
continue
i know that my dad will still be proud
that
one word syria has become synonymous
with
conflict brutality and suffering
a decade on the legacy of misery and
displacement
still rolls around the world adam
parsons sky news
berlin